EDGE AND IT WILL DETERMINE THE
LENGTH OF THIS TRIAL.
>> Laura: WE ARE ON IT AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING THERE
TONIGHT.
EARLIER I MENTIONED THE NSC’S
LETTER TO THE ATTORNEY OF
JOHN BOLTON.
I WANT YOU TO REMEMBER THE
CONTENTS OF HIS UNPUBLISHED
MANUSCRIPT WERE LEAKED TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" A FEW DAYS
AGO BUT ACCORDING TO AN NSC
LAWYER, THE MANUSCRIPT APPEARS
TO CONTAIN CLASSIFIED, PERHAPS
EVEN TOP-SECRET INFORMATION.
JOINING WHEN I WAS WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL OR KELLYANNE CONWAY.
DOES THE WHITE HOUSE CONSIDER
THIS A LEAK OF CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION?
>> PEOPLE SHOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
USE CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
I HAVE NOT SEEN THE MANUSCRIPT
OR SEEN THE BOOK, I THINK
ADAM SCHIFF OR THE MANAGERS ARE
STUCK HOLDING A BOOK WE HAVEN’T
SEEN, WE WIN AND IT COULD BE
WRAPPED UP BY THIS WEEKEND.
I CAN’T BELIEVE HOW PEOPLE ARE
LIKE ANTS ON A SUGAR CUBE EVERY
TIME THERE’S A NEW PERSON -- YOU
KNOW WITH THE BOMBSHELL
INTERVIEW WITH JOHN BOLTON WAS,
IT HAPPENED ON AUGUST 29TH.
I THINK IT’S TERRIFIC, HE TALKS
ABOUT THE CALL, THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS WITH
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY.
>> I WILL BE MEETING
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY, HE AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAVE SPOKEN
TWICE, THE PRESIDENT CALLED TO
CONGRATULATE PRESIDENT ZELENSKY
ON HIS ELECTION AND ON HIS
SUCCESS IN THE PARLIAMENTARY
ELECTION, THEY WERE WARM AND
CORDIAL CALLS, THEY WERE HOPING
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO MEET IN
WARSAW AFTER A FEW MINUTES
TOGETHER.
>> Laura: WE HAVE AN
INTERESTING FLASHBACK FROM 2010
WHEN JOHN BOLTON WAS TALKING
ABOUT SOMETIMES HE MIGHT NEED TO
LIVE FOR HIS SAKE OF HIS VIEW OF
NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> DID YOU EVER LIVE FOR YOUR
COUNTRY?
>> I DON’T THINK SO KNOWINGLY
BUT I CERTAINLY AM ABLE TO SPIN
THINGS AND A GOOD DIPLOMAT IS
ABLE TO SPIN THINGS JUST LIKE
AMERICAN POLITICIANS.
>> YOU WOULD LIE IN ORDER TO
PRESERVE THE TRUTH?
>> IF I HAD TO SAY SOMETHING I
KNEW WAS FALSE TO PROTECT
AMERICAN NATIONAL SECURITY, I
WOULD DO IT.
>> Laura: HE WOULD LIKE TO
PRESERVE NATIONAL SECURITY,
PERHAPS JOHN BOLTON THINKS
DONALD TRUMP IS A THREAT TO
NATIONAL SECURITY AND THAT’S WHY
HE’S GOING TO SPIN WHAT HE
SPENDS NOW.
>> I WAS REALLY STRUCK BY HIS
AUGUST 29TH INTERVIEW.
A FULL FIVE WEEKS AFTER HIS
SECOND ZELINSKI CALL.
JOHN BOLTON’S INTERVIEW AND
DONALD TRUMP DONALD TRUMP’S CALL
OF VOLODYMYR ZELENSKY ARE
SIMILAR IN THIS WAY.
I DON’T HEAR THE WORD AID,
DEMAND, I DON’T HEAR JOHN BOLTON
TALKING ABOUT BIDEN OR COOKING
UP SOME DRUG DEAL, THAT COMES UP
LATER AFTER HE LEFT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
IF PEOPLE WEREN’T SOUNDING THE
ALARM’S AT THE TIME OF THE ONLY
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SOUNDED THAT
ALARM ARE PEOPLE WHO DISAGREE
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
IF YOU DISAGREE WITH
PRESIDENT ABOUT POLICY, I HAVE A
GREAT IDEA, RUN FOR PRESIDENT,
WIN, THEN YOU CAN SET THE POLICY
POLICY.
I THINK THIS ENTIRE IMPEACHMENT
IN THE SENATE -- I HAVE TO GIVE
A LOT OF CREDIT TO THE
WHITE HOUSE’S LAWYERS FOR THIS
REASON.
THEY LOOK LIKE LAWYERS IN A
COURT ROOM, THEY ARE TAKING IT
VERY SOLEMNLY AND I THOUGHT
TODAY WAS GREAT BECAUSE YOU HAVE
CENTERS ASKING QUESTIONS, THAT’S
FAR MORE IMPORTANT THAN
WITNESSES.
WE HEARD FROM 17 WITNESSES, WE
ARE 0 FOR 17 IN TERMS OF BEING
ABLE TO CALL WITNESSES AND THAT
IS WHY SOME OF THESE SENATORS
EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE UP FOR
REELECTION THIS YEAR ARE SAYING
I DON’T NEED TO HEAR FROM THE
18TH, 19TH, 20TH WITNESS.
THE DEMOCRATS BLEW IT IN THE
HOUSE BECAUSE THERE WITNESSES
WERE A BUNCH OF LAW PROFESSORS
AND EACH OTHER.
>> Laura: ALAN DERSHOWITZ WAS
UP LATE TONIGHT ONE OF THE LAST
PEOPLE TO SPEAK AND HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE PHRASE THEY
KEEP THROWING OUT, "NOBODY IS
ABOVE THE LAW" AND HE TURNED IT
ON THE DEMOCRATS.
>> ANYTHING THE HOUSE WANTS TO
DO TO IMPEACH IS IMPEACHABLE,
THAT IS WHAT HAS HAPPENED TODAY.
THAT PLACES THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES ABOVE THE LAW,
WE HEARD MUCH ABOUT HOW NO ONE
IS ABOVE THE LAW, THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES IS NOT ABOVE THE
LAW.
>> Laura: THEY WANT TO BE ABLE
TO CALL THE PRESIDENT GUILTY OF
EXTORTION, CONSPIRING WITH THE
RUSSIANS, THEY WERE SAYING ALL
THIS STUFF DEFAMING THE
PRESIDENT, NONE OF THAT WAS IN
THE ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT.
THEY THINK THEY CAN DO IT WITH
IMPUNITY BECAUSE THEY HAVE
IMMUNITY, THEY WERE SAYING IT IN
THE HALLS OF CONGRESS.
>> THE LAWYERS AREN’T DOING
THAT, THE HOUSE MANAGERS ARE.
IT’S A TERRIBLE MISTAKE FOR
DEMOCRATS TO PUT UP A NAKEDLY
PARTISAN POLITICIANS WERE
PREENING FOR THE CAMERA AS THEIR
PROSECUTORS BECAUSE THEY
PROBABLY OFFENDED THE JURY.
WHEN YOU’RE GIVING YOUR OPINION,
CONJECTURE, ASSUMPTION, WISHFUL
THINKING, YOU’RE NOT PROVIDING
EVIDENCE OR FACTS.
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS WHERE DO
YOU HAVE ANY EVIDENCE OF X, THEY
REPEATED THEMSELVES, THEY THINK
THEY ARE ON A TV SHOW.
>> Laura: A LOT OF FOLKS ARE
REACHING OUT ON TWITTER TO ME,
WE’VE BEEN COVERING THE LEGAL
ASPECTS OF THIS CASE SAYING WHY
IS IT THE WHITE HOUSE SEEMS TO
HAVE PEOPLE BURROWED IN FROM
OTHER DEPARTMENTS OR CIA WHO ARE
WORKING PERHAPS RIGHT NOW
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT’S AGENDA
IN FOREIGN POLICY, DOMESTIC
POLICY AND IS THAT NOT A
CONTINUING ACHILLES’ HEEL FOR
THIS ADMINISTRATION IF THEY ARE
STILL IN THE WHITE HOUSE TODAY?
>> IT WOULD BE IF THAT IS TRUE,
I THINK PEOPLE TALK ABOUT THE
DEEP STATE, I TALK ABOUT THE
SHALLOW STATE.
IT DOESN’T HAVE TO BE THAT DEEP
OR BE HERE THAT LONG, IF YOU ARE
WORKING AT CROSS PURPOSES TO THE
PRESIDENT’S AGENDA, HE
APPRECIATES WHEN PEOPLE PUSH
BACK OR HAVE A DISSENTING VIEW,
DIVERSITY OF OPINION.
I WAS THERE WHEN THAT WAS
EXACTLY WHAT WAS HAPPENING BUT
WORKING AT CROSS PURPOSES -- IF
YOU ARE ATTACKING THE PRESIDENCY
AND ATTACKING AGENDA AND THERE’S
SO MANY PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO
WANT TO SERVE IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Laura: ARE YOU CONFIDENT --
>> I’M NOT CONFIDENT, I’VE
EXPRESSED THAT MANY TIMES TOO
MANY PEOPLE, I AM CONFIDENT
ABOUT ONE THING.
MAGA WORLD HAS A POINT WHEN THEY
SAY THERE’S SO MANY OF US WHO
WOULD LOVE TO SERVE IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND NEVER GOT A
CHANCE, THAT’S A QUESTION FOR
PERSONNEL.
>> Laura: PRESIDENTIAL
>> FOR TRANSITION, THERE WERE
PEOPLE WHO WANTED TO SERVE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION, THEY CAN
JOIN US IN THE SECOND ONE.
>> Laura: I KEPT SAYING
THAT -- WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE AND
DIDN’T THAT WORK FOR JEB BUSH?
GOD BLESS JEB BUSH BUT --
>> I THINK THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT, THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING OUR EVIDENCE IS
OVERWHELMING, I THOUGHT WHEN
JERRY NADLER AND ZOE LOFGREN
WENT ON TV AFTER THE ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT PAST, THEY MADE A
BIG MISTAKE, THEY PROBABLY
SHOULD NOT HAVE SPOKEN PUBLICLY
BECAUSE THEY ALL SAID THE REASON
WE DID THIS IS BECAUSE THE
EVIDENCE WAS OVERWHELMING, WE
HAVE ALL WE NEED.
NOW THEY WANT MORE EVIDENCE THAT
WHAT YOU SAY IS VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE I THINK HISTORY WILL
LOOK BACK AND SAY THAT’S
TERRIBLE UKRAINE IT DIDN’T GET
IT STAYED THAT YEAR, ACTUALLY IT
DID -- IT GOT MORE.
>> Laura: NONE OF THE FACTS
CHANGED.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS PUSHED BACK
ON A LOT OF THESE BOOKS, I’M NOT
TALKING ABOUT THIS BOOK BUT A
LOT OF THESE BOOKS.
>> Laura: ALL OF THE PEOPLE
WORKING THE WHITE HOUSE TONIGHT,
IF YOU’RE WORKING IN THE
WHITE HOUSE TONIGHT YOU’RE DOING
IT AS A CIVIL SERVANT, THE IDEA
THAT YOU DINE OUT ON HAVING
SERVED AND GETTING YOUR
TAXPAYER-FUNDED PAYCHECK -- I
DON’T LIKE THE BOOK WRITERS.
I KNOW EVERYONE DOES IT COME I
THINK IT’S DISLOYAL.
>> THEY CAN USE IT TO FIGHT
THEIR AGGRESSORS AND OBAMA WAS
BASICALLY LIKE --
>> Laura: THAT POINT HAS BEEN
MADE TO.
>> THAT IS WHAT IS GOING TO COME
OUT AFTER HE’S ACQUITTED, HE
WILL SAY WHY DID UKRAINE GET HIS
AID TO?
’S BE WHAT I THINK RE-EXAMINE A
LOT OF THE FOREIGN AID.
>> HE’S BEEN MAKING PEOPLE PAY
THEIR FAIR SHARE, THAT’S WHERE